so how can we tell whether something is
true what was the very very first thing
we looked at under the heading of
calculus the very first thing we looked
at was we to differentiate we need to go
to first principles right make me a
little subheading
[Music]
now first principles isn't a very fun
quick process usually but it's useful
because when you don't know what else to
do it's your foundation it's what
everything else is built on ok so what I
want you to write with me is what is the
definition of first principles when we
use it for differentiating what does it
start with starts with that thing we
never want to keep on writing
conservative starts with a limit right
I'll come back to why that limit is
there in a second and then there's a
fraction right do you remember what the
fraction had on it after the X plus h
and then there was a difference with
minus f of X now what was this this was
the this was the rise right so we're
doing right over run here what was the
run H so what we're doing here in first
principles cast your mind all the way
back like a whole year now we're
thinking about rise over run as the run
gets really really teeny-tiny right
because we're interested in tangents not
not secant right so we actually don't
want the two points to be apart we want
them to be right together okay so this
is how first principles and looks okay
and we actually can use this just fine
with this but for this particular proof
I actually want to show you a different
version of first principle is actually a
whole bunch if you've looked in a
textbook and some of you asked me this
question before I'll actually show you
another version of first principles we
can give the right one see no it should
be oh you know I'll leave it that I'll
leave it is that I'm going to write the
first principles of the granular
function but in a slightly different way
I'm going to think about rather than
this r1 getting smaller and smaller and
smaller I want to think about two values
that just approach each other that's
really the same thing okay if you write
it like that then this is what you will
find your textbook has a proof that uses
this result and I'm showing a small
number of you and you don't really need
it this is the one that will do all the
work for you but I want you to see why
it works underneath each of these let's
draw just a really simple diagram okay
what does this one look like if you were
to draw a function where are X and H and
X plus h where are they going to be well
we pick some value X and then we go
forward this little distance H like this
far so if that is a that is a trailer
where's X plus h in this diagram it's
this coordinate over here right because
you're at X plus h okay where's f of X
plus h now what does it correspond to
you remember where it is it's on the
numerator what was the numerator this
function again but it's stand for it's
it's rise and that's run yeah so here's
your f of X plus h and you're
subtracting f of X down here and there's
your rise okay what would the diagram
look like for this one draw it with me
we're gonna have the same kind of
picture but all that labels are going to
be slightly different
you still start at some point X wherever
you like
right but the place we're going to go
well I've done it backwards sorry
he's going to be somewhere else that's
not far away but I want to compare the
difference between these so that's why
it's X minus C you see how that's the
run now maybe I'll write that for you
run is that okay
do you see it so now where's f of X and
f of C where do they come into this
diagram where did they come in over here
they're about the rise yeah so here's f
of X there's f of C can you see the rise
now you see how that corresponds to the
numerator rise okay
now the reason why I highlight this is
to show you that the same thing the same
thing doesn't have to have the same
letters or exactly the same structure
okay but it's still doing the same thing
still a limit it still got rise over run
and there's a particular version of this
that just makes this super easy to fall
out okay the proof of this one is in
your textbook but it's about three times
longer than the one that I'm going to
show you so that's why I'm going to give
you this slightly different version okay
I'm going to draw one more diagram down
here
it's gonna look really strange for a
second it's going to look needlessly
complicated but I want you to think in
your mind as we go through this why it's
actually gonna make something really
nice and dramatically simpler you know
how we usually start at an X and then we
like go left or we go right like a
little distance or H or whatever
for this one I'm actually gonna go both
directions
I'm gonna go eight units that way to the
left and I'm gonna go H units this way
to the right think with me not a trick
question what's the right hand
coordinate going to be you recognize
this one already it's X plus h because
you're it to the right without the other
one X minus Q going the opposite
direction no big deal okay so what's my
run going to be look carefully
I went H that way and H that way so in
total it should be 2h are you okay with
that 2h you're thinking what why'd you
do that why would you make that
complicate and have two H's rather than
one hold with me okay let's think about
the rise the rise what's this top one
going to be F of what s / x + H what
about the bottom one f of X minus H do
you see that that's your starting point
over there there's your ending point
okay